[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen last speaker
this morning
deborah you know what
i have to stop drinking decaf i'm gonna
hand you the microphone
no problem okay i am so excited today
uh to talk to you about teacups giraffes
and our markdown
my name is desiree de leon and today i'm
going to be talking to you about a
project that i worked on with my
co-author hassa wallam
last year to make teaching and learning
statistics
a little bit more inviting fun and
intuitive and this was all done
using only in our markdown website so my
goal here today for the next 15 minutes
is to kind of give you a quick tour
around this project
and hopefully give you some ideas for
what's possible
with html output of our markdown so that
you can incorporate some of these things
into your own materials
in the future
okay so let's start with the problem uh
when teaching something that
has the potential to be a little bit dry
what is it that makes it difficult to
motivate learners
within our own local academic circles
haas and i had gotten the impression
that many people saw statistics as
either
something unintuitive scary
or very boring and we wanted to see if
we could do something about that
so we thought let's teach a really cool
seminar stats seminar at our university
and we were pretty excited about this
idea
but for reasons of red tape our idea for
teaching got squashed
but we decided that we still wanted to
make that content and put it online
but then that introduces a second
problem which is that we now lose that
precious
face-to-face time with students in a
classroom
uh that usually adds an additional
hurdle for engagement
unless we could come up with a way to
keep that content compelling
and so we thought that we could try this
by nesting our statistics lessons inside
of a story
and we all know that for a good story
you need
good characters so really early on in
our process we started to brainstorm
some heroes
that could play the protagonists
throughout our statistical content that
we were going to be building
and ultimately we came up with the
teacup giraffe
which is our fictional little species
named for its tiny stature
and so now we had this hero for all of
our stats modules and we could begin to
make up data about
it and build a story around it and so i
just want to give you a small sampler of
what this
narrative is like so there are two
distinct populations of teacup giraffes
each inhabiting their own remote islands
and as the learner coming to our site
you play the role of the graduate
student
and you've been tasked with uh
collecting data about this mysterious
little species
which uh the most sought after data is
about their height which on both islands
is variable
uh teacup giraffes also really love
eating celery
and so by assessing how much of it that
they eat you now have an additional
variable to measure
and all the while that you're collecting
this data
you deal with really demanding emails
from your advisor back at home
who needs gg plots and other results for
these data
and he needs them now but hopefully
uh teacup giraffes make that a little
bit less stressful
so with this now you've gotten a little
bit of a sampler of the teacup giraffes
world and and this is actually what
served as our backdrop for
our equations our code and all of our
exercises that we built
and actually uh we we went a little bit
overboard in creating this world
because we wrote an entire backstory
that was completely separate from the
stats content
and it's all about how the giraffes were
discovered a little bit about their
silly behavior
um and at this point you're probably
thinking it's reaching the level of
absurdity
and and i actually agree with you um but
we act
we hope that all of this storyboarding
would really help to suck learners in
and and not only learners because
uh as content creators we also got
sucked into the teacup giraffe world
quite literally
okay but silliness aside if you do have
some creative muscle that you'd like to
flex
then creating your own good characters
is a great way to do that with your
educational content
all of the character elements that i've
shown you so far here are illustrations
that i made
on an ipad pro using the procreate app
but in case drawing your own characters
is not a possibility
there are many other resources where you
can find really great high-res
and open source images and and one of
those is unsplash.com so i point you
there for really strong visuals
okay so usually at this point uh of
introducing the project to someone most
people think that we've actually made a
children's book
and not a stats website but our teacup
giraffes do have some more utility than
just
ramping up the delight meter we
specifically created our character
with our lessons in mind so in
particular we could make things like
statistical concepts like the variance
a little bit less abstract because not
only do our teacup giraffes provide
strong visuals for word problems like
for example asking
what percentage of giraffes in our
population will be shorter than this
little guy here
but maybe a more subtle benefit is that
we can use our character
to link to otherwise less intuitive
concepts
for example by using the spots the color
of the spots on our characters
to show and illustrate the concept of
the sum of squares and how you build
that
which is a precursor for calculating the
variance
so with good characters we now had one
pillar in place to help make our content
feel a little bit more friendly
and the next step was to include good
play
and by that i mean taking full advantage
of the html output that you get with our
markdown
by inserting movement and interaction so
that the learner actually has something
that they can do on your site
and i just want to share five examples
of packages and tools that we found most
useful for this
the first one is plotly so plotley
lets you create clickable and
interactive plot so that a learner can
see a concept play out in real time
this for example is a plotly plot that
we used
to explain why the equation for sample
variance needs to be divided by
n minus one and we of course explain
this in the text before showing this
plot
and another good thing that you can use
for good play is the gifski package
which lets you make gifs and so once
you've installed gifski
you can include an animation hook in the
codes
in the code chunk settings and this will
stitch together any plots that are
output
from that code chunk so this gif here
was made by throwing several gg plots in
one code chunk and then looping through
all of them
with something like either a per
function or an apply function
but you can actually use the ski hook to
make gifs out of regular images as well
so you're not just limited to gg plots
this is a gif that we made to represent
very abstractly
the process of going from cross products
to covariances and then standardizing
those
to become correlation scores
but the most important part of good play
that we wanted to give our learners
was the ability to go through some stats
methods
by hand or in other words we wanted
learners to have a chance to break apart
functions write their own functions at
least once to kind of eliminate that
statistical black box feeling
and in order to do that we needed
interactive console windows in our site
so our solution was to take a learn our
window
and embed it into our markdown website
here's an example of how this works so
if you have not seen the learn our
package before
learn our documents are our markdown
documents that can be used as
interactive tutorials and they usually
exist as standalone things or
stand-alone apps but what's really cool
about them is that they have these
built-in little consoles so you can
pre-load code into them for a learner or
text
you can also pre-load solutions which a
user can then
run and see their output and that's
great
so one of the problems however is that
when a user is using a learnr
document and the iframe it's a little
tricky to get it to
resize appropriately when the user is
interacting with it and so a solution to
do
to get it to resize appropriately is to
use a little bit of javascript
and in particular something called an
iframe resizer which
does exactly what it sounds like um so
to our knowledge this is the first time
that someone's applied an iframe resizer
to a learner window that's inside of an
iframe
and the process for it's a little bit
involved so i'm not going to cover the
details here
but i have created a step-by-step guide
that shows you how to do this
in your owner markdown documents and you
can find that
on my blog which is at desiree.rbind.io
and learner windows are not the only
things that you can embed of course
there are two more quick pieces of good
play that i'd like to share with you
that are considerably
easier to embed in your site so first
there's a regular shiny app like this
one which we used
to have learners guess correlation
values and using the same i from a pr
iframe approach you can also embed quiz
questions and we haven't yet
done this in our project but we look
forward to asking really tough quiz
questions like this one
okay so by using plotly gifsky lernar
and shinee
we could make our markdown site so much
more interactive
and there's still one more piece missing
that i'd like to share though about our
site and that is
good design and so by this i mean the
page layout
and styling that's distinct from the
content but
brings good vibes and a sense of polish
to your product
so essentially judging a book by its
cover or by extension
um judging a site by its html and
css and while this is of course not the
best way to measure the quality of your
content
the degree of styling that you give your
site
not only changes a learner's first
impression when they first see your page
but it can also improve readability
navigation and the user's general
experience as they go through your
content
so out of the box here is what our
markdown site might have looked like
just using the default
settings for on our markdown website and
this is a decent start but i want to
share three things that i think deliver
some pretty big impact and the first is
decluttering so we do this by getting
rid of
borders and highlights and numbers that
are not absolutely essential to our
output
and then we can add a whole lot more
white space so
things don't feel so cramped so around
the table of contents between paragraphs
and headers
we can also constrain the width of the
body of the text
and finally we can increase font size
and the line height of the paragraph too
and so once we've made these changes we
get a lot more breathing room on the
page and it's easier to read
most of these changes do involve a
little bit of css but if that scares you
one non-css thing that you can do in
your markdown document
straight in the document itself is just
by adding backslashes or line breaks
line breaks on their own lines and
adding that space in between is manually
something that
goes a long way when it when it comes to
making more breathing room
and so here's kind of the before and
after just with these like right off the
bat
changes of more white space and
breathing room
the second thing i want to share about
good design is setting the visual
ambiance for the site by adding a big
image to the top which
in the lingo is called a hero image and
so you can do this
if you're familiar with the our markdown
setting for the includes before body
option and you can just insert a file in
there that references
some big image to go at the very top of
your page
and finally making use of built-in
features of pandoc which is what runs
under
under the hood of our markdown to make
things like note boxes
so these can help organize your page
content and help call out things like
instructions or notes or critical
thinking questions for your learners
here we've used them to encase the
learning objectives for this particular
module
and the step-by-step process for making
these noteboxes is also something that
you can find on my blog
so there are some other things that you
can tweak as well things like
adding a logo google fonts you can
customize your navbar
and these and many other good design
elements i've shown you today
are things that again involve some css
if your experience with css in the past
has been
either difficult or non-existent i hope
that this does not stop you
so this past summer i interned with at
our studio with allison hill
and we started to create some our
markdown templates so that you can
create these very same layouts kind of
in
an out-of-the-box way these two are
still works in progress but the
resources
called rstudio for edu and rmd for edu
will be coming to
um a github repository near you so you
can keep a look out for those
later this year so now i've shown you
some examples of good characters good
play and good design and i think it's
worth mentioning that all of these
things
are things that huss and i did without
ever needing to leave the comfort
of our favorite ide and
with that i can now show you what it
looks like when you put all of these
things together
so if you'd like to check out the
wonderful world of teacups giraffes and
statistics you can do that
at bitly giraffe stats for the best
experience i recommend right now
doing that on desktop and in the chrome
browser but
the source code for all of this project
is something that you can also get to by
clicking on the
github logo in the nav bar of the site
and that'll take you straight to the
github
for it we're still in development as for
this project and we're just starting to
test this out with real
live learners but we welcome github
issues and blog comments or come find us
at some point we'd love to get your
feedback
and hear your questions about it i hope
this has given you some
ideas for what's possible to make when
you're teaching with our markdown
and we hope that you can incorporate
some good characters good play and good
design
in your next project and so with that
i'd like to thank my co-author
hasawalam for being the other half of
this project alison hill for helping me
package up so many of these designs and
layouts in a way that i'll be able to
share
with all of you soon and also carl and
the rest of the education team for their
support of the giraffe project
and if you want to hear um or if you
want to find out more about me or see
what i'm posting on twitter
you can do that at these different
handles and thank you guys so much for
your attention
[Applause]
so first that's the first time i've ever
had somebody come in
exactly on time to the second so well
done
first question for people with no design
background
do you have any recommended resources or
starting points
yeah certainly so um the things that
i've been developing with allison hill i
think will be a great
start for that so that um our our studio
for edu i mean again those things are
still in development but
i think it's important to note so when
when haas and i started this project
neither of us had any knowledge of css
it was it mostly started off as
um oh like we saw this really cool thing
online let's like
start googling is this possible to do
with
our markdown and you know we didn't know
the right search terms or anything like
that so
so i think if you have enough um grit
and and perseverance you can get
anything that you see
out there on the internet uh to work
with our markdown
um but the the things i'm working on
with allison will hopefully make that
process easier
okay and the second one is how are you
going to tell whether this is actually
helping people with the stats yeah
that's a great question so
um that comes that comes as soon as we
start
getting feedback from real learners we
have google analytics up which are
helpful to some degree but um
but i think we need to pilot this out in
real classrooms to see what the
in-person learner thinks about it and
then
and then from there we can think more
creatively about how to get feedback
from online learners
okay third question is have you been
thinking about taking this to the
general public you know the sort of
audience that our previous speaker was
talking about
yeah so i mean i guess the idea is that
we want to reach as many people as
possible that was part of the reason why
we wanted to make this content feel
as friendly and fun as we hope that it
does
i mean if if we can make something
appealing to people who have
never even previously thought they'd be
interested in stats then we think that
we can reach a lot of different
communities and and groups of people so
next step
okay and last question before we break
for lunch um you said that a lot of
people looked at this and thought that
you were actually writing a children's
book instead
have you thought about writing a
children's book
i would love to write a children's book
um
i've i guess i have writ well i've
helped with a children's book one that
is co-authored
by greg wilson um that i guess i
i should we announce i don't know if you
want me to announce it or
you should turn this into a children's
book oh okay a round of applause if you
want this turned into a children's book
okay so there's your second and again
please one round of applause for all
four of our speakers
[Music]
you